♪ ♪
>> Sean: SO AS JOE BIDEN'S
DISASTROUS TRIP TO THE
MIDDLE EAST IS CONTINUING AND AS
HE PREPARES TO MEET WITH SAUDI
CROWN PRINCE IN THE COMING DAYS
TO BED FOR OIL AND GET THEM TO
SIGN OFF ON HIS IDIOTIC IRANIAN
DEAL, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
SILENT, THEY WON'T SAY WHETHER
OR NOT JOE WILL ADDRESS THE
MURDER OF JOURNALIST
JAMAL KHASHOGGI AND THE
MULTITUDE OF OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS
ATROCITIES THAT OCCUR IN
SAUDI ARABIA.
REMEMBER, JOE BLAMED ALL OF
THIS, THE MURDER, ON THE SAUDI
CROWN PRINCE BEFORE PROMISING
DURING THE 2020 CAMPAIGN TO MAKE
THE COUNTRY A "PARIAH NATION."
HERE'S YOUR CHANCE, JOE, ARE YOU
GOING TO FOLLOW THROUGH OR IS
THIS JUST ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
ENDLESS BROKEN PROMISES?
KHASHOGGI'S WIDOW BROKE HER
SILENCE IN AN EMOTIONAL
INTERVIEW WITH OUR VERY OWN
BILL HEMMER EARLIER TODAY, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> IF YOU COULD BE THERE, WHAT
WOULD YOU TELL NBS
>> I WOULD TELL HIM YOU WILL
REGRET IF YOU KNOW THE TRUTH,
AND TO ANYONE INVOLVED IN HIS
CRIME, THEY WILL REGRET.
>> Sean: INSTEAD OF COMMITTING
TO DISCUSSING THE MURDER WITH
THE SAUDI CROWN PRINCE, JOE HAD
THIS TO SAY.
>> President Biden: I WILL
BRING UP -- I ALWAYS BRING UP
HUMAN RIGHTS.
I ALWAYS BRING UP HUMAN RIGHTS,
BUT MY POSITION ON KHASHOGGI HAS
BEEN SO CLEAR.
IF ANYONE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND IT
IN SAUDI ARABIA OR ANYWHERE
ELSE, THEN THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE.
>> Sean: SO ARE YOU GOING TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
MURDER OF KHASHOGGI OR NOT?
ARE YOU THERE TO BED FOR OIL OR
NOT?
WHAT ABOUT THEIR TREATMENT OF
GAYS AND LESBIANS?
THE TREATMENT OF WOMEN?
SOME PEOPLE PUNISHED IN A NUMBER
OF GRUESOME WAYS, IN SOME CASES
JUST FOR BEING GAY.
WHAT ABOUT THEIR OPPRESSIVE LAWS
AGAINST WOMEN WHO AREN'T EVEN
ALLOWED TO DRIVE UNTIL 2018 OR
OBTAIN THEIR OWN PASSPORT UNTIL
2019, AND IT'S NOT JUST
SAUDI ARABIA BIDEN IS DOING
BUSINESS WITH.
HE'S DOUBLING DOWN ON THIS
IDIOCY OF REVIVING THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
IRAN IS THE WORLD NUMBER ONE
STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR.
THEY BOAST SIMILAR OPPRESSIVE
LAWS AGAINST WOMEN, GAY PEOPLE,
INCLUDING THE DEATH PENALTY IF
YOU ARE GAY.
ASK YOURSELF WHERE ALL THE
RADICAL HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVISTS,
ALL THE WOKE PEOPLE IN AMERICA
THAT ARE DEMOCRATS?
HOW COME THEY ARE NOT UPSET THAT
JOE IS DOING BUSINESS WITH THESE
COUNTRIES?
HERE WITH REACTION, HUMAN RIGHTS
ATTORNEY, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LAWFARE PROJECT, BROOKE
GOLDSTEIN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TAMMY BRUCE.
TAMMY, IN A WAY, I GUESS I'M THE
ONE STANDING UP FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS.
I ALWAYS HAVE.
I WOULD WANT NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANY OF THESE COUNTRIES.
I DON'T WANT THEIR MONEY, I
DON'T WANT THERE OIL.
THEY ARE HOSTILE REGIMES THAT
HAVE ATROCIOUS HUMAN RIGHTS
RECORDS.
>> THEY DO, AND YOU LAID IT OUT
PERFECTLY.
MANY HAVE NOTED THAT THE
CHANGES, THE SMALL CHANGES WHEN
IT COMES TO WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN
THE KINGDOM, WERE REALLY MADE
FOR P.R. EFFECT.
IT IS STILL VERY DIFFICULT IN
THE KINGDOM.
IN SAUDI ARABIA, HOMOSEXUALITY
IS DICTATED BY THE CRIMINAL
CODE, WHICH IS DICTATED BY
SHARIA LAW.
AND RECENT EXECUTIONS OF
HOMOSEXUALS THERE AS WELL.
IT IS HORRENDOUS, AND IT'S A
PROTECTED ENVIRONMENT IN THAT
THEY WANT TO SHOW SOMETHING
OUTSIDE TO FOREIGN COUNTRIES
WHILE IT IS STILL REPRESSIVE AND
HORRIBLY SO INTERNALLY.
BUT THIS IS MORE OF A STORY WITH
WHAT YOU OUTLINED REGARDING
JOE BIDEN.
WITH BIDEN, EVERYTHING IS
TRANSACTIONAL.
I BELIEVE THAT HE MEANT THAT
ABOUT TICS, BUT NOW LOOK AT WHAT
HE'S WILLING TO DO IN ORDER TO
KEEP AMERICA WEAK.
HE IS WILLING TO GO TO A PLACE
THAT IS KNOWN TO BE A HORRIFIC
ABUSER OF HUMAN RIGHTS BECAUSE
HIS PRIORITY IS TO KEEP HIS OWN
COUNTRY AS WEAK AS POSSIBLE.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE NATURE OF
JOE BIDEN IN A WAY THAT I THINK
SHOULD SHOCK THE CONSCIENCE OF
EVERYONE WATCHING THIS PROGRAM,
NO MATTER WHO YOU ARE.
WE BELIEVE IN HUMAN RIGHTS
BECAUSE WE ARE AMERICA.
WE ARE NOT PERFECT, BUT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT, WHEN WE LEARN
ABOUT, WHEN WE CARE ABOUT IT, WE
MEAN IT.
WITH JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS, AND PERHAPS THE
ESTABLISHMENT IN GENERAL, THIS
IS TRANSACTIONAL.
HE NOW WANTS SOMETHING FROM
SAUDI ARABIA, VENEZUELA, EVEN
RUSSIA, CHINA.
BECAUSE IT SUITS HIS PURPOSE OF
KEEPING AMERICA IN TROUBLE, AND
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE AT RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S A HORRIBLE PLACE, AND HE'S
NOW GOING TO STAND NEXT TO THIS
HORRIBLE DYNAMIC IN SAUDI ARABIA
BECAUSE IT SUITS HIM.
>> Sean: BROKE, WHERE ALL THE
WOKE LEFTISTS IN THIS COUNTRY?
WHERE ALL THE LIBERAL ACTIVIST,
HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVISTS IN THIS
COUNTRY?
BECAUSE THEIR SILENCE IS
DEAFENING AND JOE IS ONLY DOING
IT TO APPEASE THE CLIMATE
ALARMIST RELIGIOUS CULT THAT
BELIEVES IT'S OKAY TO IMPORT
OIL, BUT NOT PRODUCE IT
DOMESTICALLY.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WE ARE FACED NOW WITH THE
SITUATION WHERE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES HAS TO
EMBARRASS HIMSELF BECAUSE OF HIS
OWN POLICIES.
HE HAD TO DO A 180-DEGREE TURN
WHERE HE USED TO BE CALLING
SAUDI ARABIA A PARIAH STATE
SAYING "THEY HAVE TO PAY THE
PRICE" FOR BEING BAD, AND NOW
HE'S GOING OVER THERE BEGGING
FOR OIL BECAUSE IT IS HIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT REFUSES TO
MAKE AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENT,
AND IF THIS DUAL FACED --
TWO-FACED HYPOCRITICAL NATURED
DIPLOMACY THAT REALLY PERVADES
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
ON THE ONE HAND, YOU HAVE OUR
ALLY ISRAEL.
HE'S OVER THERE SIGNING
JERUSALEM DECLARATIONS DECLARING
THAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
IRAN FROM HAVING A NUCLEAR
WEAPON, AND THEN AT THE SAME
TIME, TURNING AROUND, PUSHING
FOR THE IRAN DEAL, REINSTATING
$200 MILLION WORTH OF FUNDING
FOR THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY
AND FOR HAMAS, A TERRORIST GROUP
IN GAZA ALLOWING THE PAY FOR
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE WHERE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO PAY TERRORIST WHO
MURDER OFTEN AMERICANS AS WELL
WHO ARE IN ISRAEL, SO THE
HYPOCRISY IS WHY WE ARE LOSING
FACE ON A DAILY BASIS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ADD ONE
THING.
THERE IS SUCH AN OUTRAGE OVER
WHAT HAPPENED WITH KHASHOGGI,
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE,
BUT WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE WHEN
AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE KILLED BY
PALESTINIAN TERRORISTS AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DOES
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING?
CONTINUES TO ALLOW AMERICAN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO FUND THIS
TERROR ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: BROKE, THANK YOU.
TAMMY AS WELL, THANK YOU.
STRAIGHT AHEAD WHY IS THE LEFT
CONTINUING TO ENCOURAGE
INCIVILITY AGAINST OUR OWN
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES?
TO ANY OF YOU HAVE THE COURAGE
TO STAND UP AND CONDEMN THESE
THREATS?
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN
WAS ASKED ABOUT IT.
THAT TAP